It's Oktoberfest!
Let's legitimize our
drinking by talking about it
scientifically.
Hey guys, Anthony
here for D News.
I've got local craft
brewer Jesse Friedman
here with me from Almanac
Brewery here in San Francisco.
All cooking is kind
of chemistry, right?
Yeah.
But brewing I find is
especially so, right?
Because it's so
specific and precise,
the way you have to get
different beers, and things
that you have to change
to make things work.
Yeah.
I often say that brewing's
a lot like baking.
OK.
You know, both involve
a lot of fermentation
if you're breadmaking, and
you sort of set up everything,
and then you just sort
of set the process loose,
and see what comes
out at the other end.
And so instead of
like cooking, where
you adjust as you cook,
and stuff like that,
with beer it's more like
you see how it comes out,
and then you go back
to the beginning
and make a new batch, and
tweak, and adjust your process.
So tell us about the
main ingredients that
are going to go into every
beer, and kind of what purposes
they serve.
So, all beer by definition
contains four ingredients.
Water, hops, yeast, and barley.
OK.
And that goes back to a
17th century German purity
law that said only
those ingredients could
be made with it.
At the time they
didn't say yeast,
because it hadn't
been discovered,
but after they found out there's
yeast, they added that in.
OK.
And so each of those
ingredients, and you
can vary all of them
in different ways
to make all the
different styles of beer.
So what makes us adhere to
the 17th century definition,
as opposed to kind
of evolving it?
Oh, we don't.
We flaunt it.
My brewery flaunts it
at every opportunity.
Excellent.
We put all sorts of
different things in our beer.
Yeah, let's talk about it.
Let's talk about some
of the other stuff
that you guys put in.
I mean, sometimes
fruit is added, right?
Yeah.
Sometimes other kinds of food.
So Almanac Beer,
we call ourselves
a farm to barrel brewery.
So we brew, we
describe our beers
as being brewed in
collaboration with local farms.
So the idea, and we use
a fancy French term here,
is to infuse a sense of
terroir into our beer.
Because beer is all made with--
all the ingredients in beer
can be dried and
easily transported.
So the idea is to go to
local agriculture systems,
and bring in fruits
and vegetables,
and local ingredients to
infuse a sense of California
back into our beer.
You know, we brew with
a lot of real fruit,
so we source that
fruit from local farms,
and then we stand
there and by hand put
all that fruit into the
barrels one piece at a time.
Gotcha.
So talk to me about the
chemistry of what goes on here.
When you throw everything
into the vat, what happens?
Well, you start out
with your barley,
and the barley is molted,
and that's usually
done by a molster.
So usually a brewery
won't do that ourselves.
And they sprout it, and then
kiln it to different levels.
And actually, that
toasting process
is how we make beer lots
of different colors.
We take that, we soak it in just
the right temperature of water
to extract out exactly
what we want out of there,
and beer brewing is one of
those great things where
the process has been evolved
over so many hundreds of years
that it's like a
self-contained process.
So when we melt all the sugars
and starches out of the barley,
the husks that are
in there actually
become a natural grain
bed that filters it out,
so you get an almost
perfectly crystal clear liquid
when you're done with that.
Then we begin a
boiling process, and we
add hops during the
boiling process.
And the hops act as
preservative, and delicious,
delicious flavoring agent.
So we add hops at the
beginning of the boil,
and that creates bitterness.
And the more hops you add
at the end of the boil,
those actually add aromas.
So you guys are
also doing something
that's kind of trendy
right now in brewing,
which is the barrel aging.
Exactly.
How does that work?
Well, that's one of those
trendy things that's
thousands of years
old, if [INAUDIBLE].
It's definitely very
in vogue, and it's
one of the most exciting parts
of the beer brewing process.
So we take the
beer, and don't just
go brew with brewer's yeast.
We sort of draw--
for how strict,
and the Germans are about
their beer brewing process,
the Belgians are
kind of the opposite.
OK.
So they'll make
beers in Belgium that
are what are called
spontaneously fermented.
So that means they make the
sugar water solution, called
wort, and then instead of adding
a very specific yeast strain,
they actually open the
windows, and whatever
drifts in through
the windows will then
create the spontaneously
fermented beer.
What?
So we drawn on that tradition
for a lot of our wild,
what are called
wilder sour ales.
OK.
So there's a--
But what drifts in
through the window?
Well, I mean, it's just like
San Francisco Sourdough.
OK.
So in San Francisco, if you
want to make San Francisco
Sourdough, step one,
go to San Francisco.
OK.
And then you just mix
some flour and some water
and put that out, and
it'll naturally inoculate.
Because we have, there's wild
yeast, there's lactobacillus,
there's all these
different bugs.
They're all around
us all the time,
it's just a matter
of culturing them.
And then as you grow them
up, the alcohol tolerant ones
will naturally weed
themselves out.
OK.
And so we use a cocktail of
while Belgian yest and some San
Francisco sourdough to
bring in that local flavor,
and we age the beer in a barrel.
In a barrel the oak is
perfect, because as it
gets warm and dark
during the day,
the barrel actually will
breathe, soaking in the beer
and pushing it back out.
So we get all those great
whisky, oaky flavors.
Wow.
That is awesome.
So, how long have
you guys been around?
Just celebrated our
two year anniversary.
That's awesome.
Happy anniversary.
Well, thank you.
And you guys have
a website, as well?
Yeah. almanacbeer.com.
Do you want to know more
about Almanac's barrel aging
process, or about the beer
brewing process at all?
There is a new show
for beer enthusiasts,
it is called Brew Age.
it's at youtube.com/brewagetv.
That starts on October
23, so check it out.
Jesse, thanks so
much for coming by.
Hey, thanks for having me.
Let's go get a beer.
Yes!